one of the hosts of the tomahawk show
with Andrew Hawkins on LeBrons
uninterrupted platform he is Joe Thomas
how are you Joe I'm doing great thanks
for having me on what'd you think of
that tie yesterday Joe let me tell you
what it was pretty exciting I don't know
how I felt after the game I think I'm
supposed to feel like there was a moral
victory that the Browns finally didn't
lose their opening game but it felt like
it was the game that they should have
won you know the Steelers put it on a
platter for him they had the opportunity
to kick a short field goal at the end of
the game to win finally and they didn't
get it done so what do you think the
answer is Joe just continue on with
whatever plan they have laid out here
just keep going on with it with their
head coach what do you think the plan
should be here well I think they've
clearly made a lot of improvement from
where they were last season so I'm not
ready to just throw out the plan because
they tied the Steelers in the opening
game but obviously I think they need to
make some big improvements clearly
offensively they didn't do enough to win
and defensively they look really good
early on the run game was not or the run
defense was not great but they fix that
and overall the defense getting all
those turnovers was outstanding
offensively I'm hoping that just because
this was the first game in Todd Haley's
offense they're gonna make some huge
improvement next game and be able to go
out run the ball more effectively throw
for some more yards and score some more
points well the line without you there
they put Desmond Harrison who's been
waiting a long time and had quite the
journey to the National Football League
in your spot what did you think of the
replacement for you I thought he had a
nice game he obviously made some
mistakes early on was a couple false
starts and there was a couple times in
the game where you noticed he he went
the wrong way he had mental assignment
errors but overall you can see why he is
being so highly regarded especially
being the undrafted rookie that he is
he's got incredible athleticism he's
really powerful and he does a lot of
things really really well he's just got
a lot of things to learn and that's to
be expected as a rookie left tackle but
overall I think he did a really nice job
for his first game is Hugh Jackson the
right man for the job Jim I absolutely
think he is I think he's a tremendous
head coach I think he really hasn't been
given
full deck up until this point and I'm
really excited to see what he does this
year with the weapons that they sign in
in the off season and I think they're
headed in the right direction right now
you saw the progress they didn't get the
win offensively they didn't have what
they needed yet but I think they're
definitely headed in the right direction
and why isn't Baker Mayfield out there
right now well I think because Tyrod
gives them the best chance to win right
now I think the best thing for Baker
Mayfield is to sit on the bench and
watch and learn and every time
tie rod has a mistake or he misses a
protection or a blitz or a throw
that's Baker Mayfield learning without
being in the fire and losing confidence
because a lot of times I think rookies
when they're pushed out there too soon
they think they know what they're doing
and all of a sudden the NFL game
happened so quickly and they lose their
confidence because they don't believe in
themself anymore when they throw three
or four picks in a game Jo Thomas here
on the Rich Eisen show let's flip the to
the other side were you surprised to
hear offensive linemen talk about their
running back who's not there because of
its business decision calling him out
for that business decision in Pittsburgh
Joe well it's a little surprising
anytime you hear NFL players
specifically teammates calling each
other out over a contract situation
generally speaking NFL players are going
to have each other's backs and they
understand this is a very violent
business it takes a lot out of you from
my physical standpoint and it's
important to try to get paid when you
get the opportunity and when you become
a free agent and B get your money but in
this situation I think it's rare and
unique because generally it seems like
the Steelers linemen think that Le'Veon
Bell is being unreasonable on his
contract demands and that's why I think
they started calling them out because I
think they want him to get paid but at
the same time they want him to be
reasonable so that they can get a deal
done and they think he's just being
unreasonable
well is there is it their place to even
comment as to what's unreasonable or
reasonable well I think there's an
argument that says it's not their place
to talk about another man's contract
situation but in this case what he does
has a big impact on how they do as a
team and as an offensive line the person
that you're blocking for has a big
impact on how well you play so really
his beef with his contract and the
organization is going to affect their
contract and their money and their team
so really I think they do have a place
in saying something about Le'Veon Bell
when he's in their mind being
unreasonable and then when James Connor
scored yesterday Joe Thomas and his
celebration obviously it's a huge moment
for him I mean a personal story for
James Caan or overcoming cancer and
getting this opportunity and bawling out
as he did that is remarkable the
celebration with him and the offensive
line all around him was viewed as maybe
a signal to levy on bail that we are all
one here and you should be here with us
did you take that out of it I think it's
it's both I think one obviously they're
excited for a young man who overcome
cancer and and it was playing really
well and he scored his first NFL
touchdown everyone was excited for him
but at the same time I think that was
the clear message that the Steelers
offensive line especially is tired of
the drama some surrounding Le'Veon Bell
and they just want somebody to show up
and go to work like they do every day I
don't think he's showing right Joe what
are you thinking it doesn't seem like it
it seems like he's gonna wait until the
last possible moment to be able to get
his credited year and he'll show up at
that moment and I think he's just
looking forward to free agents yet this
season yeah I mean that's the whole
thing though is that how do you when he
does show cuz he's gonna show he's got a
show at some point that that when he
does show I mean will there be anybody
looking at him wondering if he's all in
that he is right that he that he's up
you know gonna tap out of a game to make
sure that he's not gassed I mean yeah
well yeah that's a good point I think
it's gonna get uglier before it gets
prettier because truthfully he's gonna
have to show up like you mentioned I
mean he needs to get his credited season
to be able to get to free-agency at the
end of this season but when he does show
up I don't think he's going to be
invested I don't think he's going to be
all-in he's not gonna want to take those
hits he's not gonna want to lower that
shoulder and deliver the boom like he's
known for and I think you might see one
of these mysterious ankle injuries once
he shows up because a lot of times
that's what the guys play is
no they have to be there they don't want
to be there but they're gonna show up
and do the bare minimum and you're
really not going to get the same Le'Veon
Bell as you have in years past Joe
Thomas here on the Rich Eisen show we
saw Khalil Mack show up show out is he
the best you've ever tried to block Joe
I'm not sure I'm gonna say he's the best
I ever tried to block but he's
definitely in that top five he's a
tremendous talent I think he is the
second best defensive player in pro
football right now behind Aaron Donald
and clearly he is an unbelievable impact
player for those bears not only in the
passing game but in the run game he
completely can shut down that side of
the field and there's some people in
Oakland right now we're probably waking
up this morning it was the little
sellers remorse well I think they were
having it during the gap Jon Gruden was
trending on Twitter last night Joe and
the Raiders were 24 hours away from
kicking off themselves you know I mean
so who was who is the best that you've
tried to block then it was inaudible in
my entire career I think it was probably
Dwight Freeney I think his combination
of his spin move inside his bull rush
and his dip and speed move upfield
we're on match now I think you know by
the time Khalil max finished with his
career he may be able to claim the the
best pass rusher of my generation but
he's still young and and I think that's
what's exciting for Bears fans is you
get a guy in his prime I mean he he
still got two or three years of
improvement before he is the best that
he is going to get and that's pretty
exciting to watch what he can already do
and how he can already take over a game
at this point in his career and knowing
that he's only going to get better what
do you think of Rogers performance last
night don't you mean Jesus the way he
was resurrected from near death I mean
people had him already on the IR and he
came back and completely took over that
game it was just totally amazing the way
he can throw the ball and distribute it
to all of his receivers and and take the
ball right down the field against all
odds and win a game like that it's just
amazing so then help help everybody out
here a couple minutes left here with Joe
Thomas again check out his tomahawk show
on the uninterrupted platform with
Andrew Hawkins he's here Joe on the Rich
Eisen show help us all out for all the
let's see what something happens in week
one and what goes on in locker rooms
between week one week two to make the
overreaction Monday a little bit less
intense for people walk me through the
actual process of trying to get better
in the NFL as well as you know it well I
think the good teams in the NFL they
treat a win or a loss the exact same way
on Monday they're gonna come in they're
gonna get their shake out they're gonna
get a little bit of a workout the sweat
end they're gonna get a good meal and
then they're gonna have their team
meeting where they review the game you
know those team meetings might go up to
an hour where you're sitting there with
everybody going over the the goods and
the bads from offense defense special
teams the coach is going to give you a
ten thousand foot view of what happened
then you break up offense and defense
you start talking specifically about how
your unit performed what you need to do
to get better what you did well and then
you break up into your groups and you
review every single play again you go
through every play every person gets
graded you find out exactly how you did
what you did well what you need to
improve and you take that methodical
approach to that when Wednesday shows up
and you get back to practice you've got
your list of three or four things that
you want to work on that you need to
improve on from the week before so it's
a process I think you have to treat
every Monday the same way because you
don't want to get too high and and gloss
over the little things when you're
winning and you also don't want to beat
yourself up too much when you lose
because in the NFL two or three plays
are going to be the difference between
losing and winning and so you don't want
to forget about the other 6465 plays
during the game just because the outcome
went one way or the other ask him the
poll question as we send him out the
door Chris all right all right Joe what
was the most OEM G moment from yesterday
Le'Veon Bell not showing up giving up
that 850,000 dollar paycheck Aaron
Rodgers returns to lead the Packer
comeback Saints giving up 48 points at
home to fits magic Browns not losing
well being the great football
nostradamus that I am I said on my
tomahawk podcast just a few days ago
that the Saints we're gonna win the
Super Bowl in the Tampa Bay Buccaneers
we're going to be the worst team in the
NFL so om G moment for me that was
unbelievable
I mean Fitz Fitzpatrick is just it he's
got like it's what I'm talking about
boom or bust I mean it's unbelievable
there's not a window he doesn't think he
could fit it in but he also showed what
how this offense can work right Joe well
I think it's interesting you watch a guy
like Ryan Fitzpatrick and people leave
him for dead then I lost all of a sudden
he comes back and throws for 500 yards
and leads a team that nobody really has
a lot of respect for to victory it's
pretty amazing he's pretty much just
bought himself three more years in the
NFL no matter how many picks he throws
from here on out that's true that's true
so did you miss it yesterday did you
miss the game yesterday Joe you know
it's funny that's the question everybody
asked me this offseason and going into
this game I hadn't had that moment where
I was like wow I really miss it even
watching hard knocks and seeing all my
brothers out there for the Browns I
didn't really miss it but then you turn
it on an opening day it just got
something special when you watch those
players running out of that tunnel and
that emotion is real for the first time
you see the fans there and the pageantry
and the pomp and circumstance that's
around opening day and then you just
think back to my 11 years in the NFL and
the emotion that came over your body on
opening day it's just unlike anything
else and it was at that moment where I
really felt like I've missed it but
there was still that that feeling in the
back of my head that my body just is not
willing and could not take any more
pounding so I did feel comfortable even
though I really missed it I felt
comfortable that I made the right
decision when IRA decided to retire
you're comfortable today basically is
what you're saying I got out of bed and
I didn't need a walker and so I felt
really good about myself that I didn't
play in a game yet hey Joe love your pod
man Congrats on it keep keep throwing it
keep it I appreciate it you got it that
said let's let's chat again soon that's
Joe Thomas at Joe Thomas 73 love love
his takes love his personality to love
everything the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience